on the shores of Lake Victoria this is
where Uganda's next generation of
runners comes to train rasheed ET au is
one of the hopefuls at Antibes athletics
club the 19 year old sprinter spends
most of its time training and improving
his personal bests some fighting really
happened I think I can make it in 800
meters it's really actually give me
exposure to the old world if I go there
and run and win then it's way helped me
it's a little-known fact but Uganda has
won two golds at the Olympics one in
1972 for 400 hurdles and the most recent
at the London Games in the men's
marathon but the national youth coach
moses' Sonya wants to see his country on
the podium again we are lacking medals
in this country so my main aim is to
train them and win medals for this
country as one of Uganda's most
successful sprinters Oh Sonya wants to
pass on his knowledge to other aspiring
athletes that is what inspired a Sonia
to set up the athletics club two years
ago he's also helped finance it among
the challengers a lack of training
grounds the team meets daily at a rented
cricket field many athletes here a short
distance runners mainly recruited from
outside the cities we have - all my
potential here in Uganda if the
government could really come up the
government could come up with the
programs support the Federation okay go
to various defeats you see we have
potential runners in this country and he
is seen as a metal hopeful but it's been
a long journey he grew up in humble
surroundings hundreds of kilometers away
from the capital Kampala his family
couldn't support him financially with a
Sonia's help he can dedicate himself to
achieving his goals about winning
so my coach is behind me and I know I'm
a kitty always tell me that I said
you're good and only keep training and
I'm training with him together with some
other guys so I know I'll make it one
day at the recent national trials
Estonia tested some of his runners
against other athletes in Uganda five of
a Sonia's Academy products including a
tiao have finally made it to the
national team the main priority now for
a tio and his teammates is to replicate
past athletic successes
Uganda's two gold medals at the Olympics
in London and Munich remain a shining
example for the runners and Nicole Moses
a Sonia